I was scandalized by what was set coming
from Turkey on the Netherlands on
Germany and on others I will never
accept this comparison between the Nazis
and no governments you know my home
country Luxembourg was occupied by the
Nazis our people were suffering my
father was forced into the German army
together with his three brothers
brothers if you are establishing a
comparison of that period with our times
this is totally unacceptable and the one
who is doing this is taking distance
from Europe and not trying to enter
European Union European Union is not
joining Turkey turkey is joining
European you
[Applause]